[Música]
e aí ela que assistiu canal do bom você
em do eu isso não lhe dando este canal
em que aparece aqui uma vez por ano 7 me
desculpem por avisar a todos vocês que
estão aqui me assistindo agora toda avó
eu posso eu faço um show off shores a
funcionar não sabe fazer show estão
produção indisponível faço toda vez que
eu posso de vod show agora como e depois
de neve no rio de janeiro vai preencher
esse o grande momento de votar no dia 25
de julho no teatro odilon costa aí no
rio de janeiro às quatro horas da tarde
pode comprar seu ingresso online é só
entrar no ingresso certo ponto com
gasques lá o ensino de campo grande a
galera me cobra muito interação então
por isso hoje eu vou fazer um vídeo
respondendo às perguntas de você e as
perguntas do instagram é quem responde
pelo twitter perguntando do facebook
hoje não falei que faz com dez perguntas
que me fizeram no instagram beleza o
caso velho perguntou curte qo a galera
falar em juízo mas o riso com isso você
só fala portar em seus vídeos não lembra
que têm crianças de assistindo você não
lembra que têm crianças é assistindo a
primeira pergunta que eu sou curto sim
gosto muito curto é porque eu tenho um e
ele falar muito por mim é obrigação de
gostar yamaha e se cumpriu com aquilo
a m3 lei esse ponto ainda está pensando
qual foi a coisa mais louca que você já
fez a mesma coisa mais louca que eu já
fiz na minha vida é mais assim mas vai
dormir onde se vou restantes jovens que
eu tomei foi 3 tarde nome de uma vez que
fui louco a onu no haiti disse riordan e
perguntou se você fosse mulher estivesse
menstruado de calça branca e alguém te
avisar que você tava melada de sangue
que desculpa você iria dar e olhar no
olho da pessoa dizer sim o meu deus e
fez em cima do meu filho mulher
joão pedro m de perto o que você acha da
seleção brasileira atualmente essa
brasileira faltar não é normal a galera
falar assim mas é porque antigamente a
seleção brasileira ganhava tudo azul da
seleção jogar nem o tempo foi passando
as pessoas foi se aperfeiçoando amigo
vai jogar hoje contra tem data o bagulho
é gol de bicicleta é matar no peito
ainda domina no pé já dá pra cima roda
java mulher pra cima bate embaixadinha
com perna com a bola na outra com a
mulher joga pra cima show da manhã parte
bancada show de paul in a pessoa foi de
jogar brasil que parou no tempo
guimarães underline souza 16 18 disse
jádel a bundinha deu uma risadinha o
site online suíte isto nasceu foi assim
o fez curso no senai
não eu aprendi com meu pai dean deixar
no chão
o billzinho perguntou quando você não
consegue tirar foto com fã ou dar um
abraço e um fã como se sente às vezes eu
me sinto mal nem que eu não consigo dar
um abraço e tirar fotos vezes eu me
sinto mal quando uma fã tira 578 foto
grita pula e fica fazendo algazarra e
paetê talvez outra fã só queria uma
única foto único abraçou de dizer o
quanto ela gosta porque ela gosta de
funk que por que motivo ela assistiu 11
e ela não pode fazer isso porque tem
outra que toma totalmente o tempo e às
vezes é o seguinte até meu show apoia
direto para o hotel às vezes eu fico mal
mais por isso uma pessoa que não gosta
tanto de mentira 15 20 fotos só postar
no facebook mesmo a mostra tirar foto e
talvez a pensar que talvez precisasse
falar comigo queria falar comigo não
pode falar porque o outro tomou tempo
porém o vinícius furtado 98 diz qual é o
seu nome de guerra é stefhany mecanismo
de bônus e raad raio nem se fala disse
que o joão underline pedro m de pinto
coca opex guaraná jesus que só jesus são
hh bieffe toleto beijar na boca de um
cachorro faria sexo mas quem nasceu
primeiro o ovo ou a galinha
primeiro foi meu só votava a raoni
adelaide 23 botou entre aspas vai cagar
rodando como você explicaria a seguinte
frase o meu deus o que é raro que a
gente nunca acabou rodando a torre
besteira h rodando é muito fácil jeito
você sempre não vá ver aí você começa
neco você sente desconfortável com essa
posição é você traz o nome dele ou cena
já me jogou fora do vaso seu filho quer
saber quando foi objeto foi dentro do
vaso a vitória dela gabriela moreira
pinto se você não fosse o humorista o
que você seria mais um realce vai poder
levar nosso bem se você vai querer o
conjunto completo com batata
refrigerante gabriel 2 albert você
trocaria a bia pra namorar com a bruna
marquezine olha vou contar uma coisa pra
vocês eu ea bia a gente tem em cada 13
artistas que a gente poderia entrar em
um outro agente a perdoar porque na
verdade são artistas muito que por não
tem como negar né ela pode ser vista e
ficaria com brad pitt e johnny depp e
com o derrota não é eu perdoaria todos
não sei se depois do the rock ainda
queria namorar com ela porque ele
poderia eu acho que ela já não é para
estar amanhã eu tenho três também
celebridades que eu posso pegar só que
eu não sou besta e pode ser novidade que
está mais ao meu alcance nem ela bota o
estado não bota aqui para falar do
syndarma o que é uma miss brasil a banda
marquezine paula oliveira que também é
que o topo em um programa e aaaron
conversar porque toalhas ponto e do
biscoito ou bolacha quando comprou um
ano fico perguntando o que é que ele é
não eu só faço com o meio então é isso
aí muito obrigado a mexer se viu até
aqui galera do rio de janeiro não se
esqueça do rio de janeiro não se esqueça
dia 25 no teatro odylo costa 4 horas da
tarde é nóis ingressos no ingresso certo
ponto com sua compra é de falar é nóis